hello this is Hank green recording live
from the Gadsden Public Library in
Gadsden Alabama and I just wanted to say
to you that John Green should have
become president but he lost to this
scoundrel named Barack Obama I will
never forget John Green's historic run
for the office John Green 2008 always
remember the power of the John Green I
would totally not have been his vice
president though not a job I would want
we got here early so I decided to make a
little video I also found my camcorder
which is very exciting I can't show it
to you because I'm filming myself with
it I have a really big zit right between
my eyes that's too bad
why do I have a big zit I've been
washing my face religiously I've been
watching everything religiously because
I really don't want to get sick on this
tour so what we got here we've got a
pile of my CDs haven't actually showed
it on on live on the air before there it
is
and here's the back and if you freeze it
you can see what all and there's the
disc itself looks like a chicken being
run over by a car and designed by shark
i jones youtube.com slash shark i jones
one of the greatest illustrators of our
generation over here we have John's
signing table with his Mac but he's gone
off somewhere probably to the bathroom
he gets a really big chair and I get a
little chair and then we have a big
stack of John's books here we have shark
nerdfighter on it and down here we have
a Katherine reading a paper towns right
there we have our magical device that
lets us be on the internet right now we
have that little thing so that we can be
right now on blogtv which we are and
we're gonna be broadcasting the entire
gaps in event on blogtv so if you want
to you can see the link in the sidebar I
think at all I'll see you guys on TV